and this virus and this pandemic
i think the the the great thing that
will come out of this horrible
experience that we've all had is
psychologically death
learning just so many bad things
occurred the economy people losing their
jobs
but we also got to see the human spirit
with these mrna vaccines
and and just how if we
took out some of the regulation and
people were super motivated
we might actually be able to eliminate
all
uh pandemics from ever happening again
and before that bill gates was banging
his fist and jeff skull was doing
the movie contagion i mean for two
decades people have been banging their
face we have to be prepared for this
yes and everybody's like yeah whatever
yolo it's not going to happen
and now it's happened and people are
like we need to be able to destroy
every you know pandemic and virus
before it happens and you're listening
you know a lot more about science than i
do but this
mr mrna has been around for a while
we've just never
gotten aggressive about doing it and
then you think about challenge trials
i don't know if you've been following
this but they're doing challenge trials
now in the uk
this month where they're introducing
kovid
into healthy young patients and then
giving them the vaccine or
you know and that is against all
yeah rules and regulations about
you know do no harm but then you think
about it
we kind of celebrate people jumping out
of planes and we got that one guy alex
honnold who's
climbing up mountains without a rope and
they give him a north star
you know backpage ad and a a you know an
endorsement deal
yeah and we celebrate that we celebrate
people
surfing with sharks we celebrate people
doing deep welding we pay them extra to
go
200 feet underground and weld stuff and
people do dangerous stuff all day long
astronauts but we will
soldiers firefighters but we won't let
people
get paid to be do a challenge trial yeah
we're weirdly risk-averse in certain
areas that completely don't make any
sense
and this is where the world needs it we
we could have said these thousand people
young people who we know are in all
likelihood not going to have a bad
outcome
but there's a possibility there's a
possibility but it's very low and it's
certainly lower than
riding a motorcycle right it's lower
than riding on motorcycles people ride
motorcycles everywhere we have ads for
motorcycles
we could have just said to those
thousand people we'll give you a million
dollars each
to do this okay there's your billion
dollars
we we're printing trillions of dollars
of money to deal with this if we had
just done
a thousand people for a million dollars
each to do a challenge trial in
march april may when they had the mrna
vaccines ready
we could have deployed the vaccines in
the summer we would have been done with
this
it would have been over by now so we get
to challenge all of that thinking i
think that's what the great pause did
it's letting everybody challenge that
thinking is why do we have that rule
okay yeah we don't want to have people
you know like
give up their organs for money like we
obviously understand but there's a
reasonable discussion about
well maybe there's a level of risk in a
global pandemic i mean we fought the
nazis
right we defeated the nazis that that
took a lot of deaths to do that but we
had to
kill that evil this is another evil
which we must
fight and it's going to result in it's
already resulting in thousands of people
dying a day but
we could have actually stopped it
earlier if we just had a reasonable
discussion this is why podcasting as i
respect what you do
this is why intelligent people are so
drawn to podcasts because you and i
can expand on this yes and not cancel
each other
over this very suggestion when i make
this suggestion that are challenge
trials reasonable or not
if i were to do that on twitter they'd
be like oh calacanis wants to
give poor people corona virus in order
to save rich people
yeah no i didn't say that but
we you and i could have a reasonable
discussion about a challenge trial is
something we should consider
in a acute situation where millions of
people are going to lose their lives
all right so you know that's an example
of capitalism and competition working
really well
there there's one of the to me sad thing
to see about coronavirus is that for
example testing
at scale should have it seems obvious i
i was a little clueless about it but
because i thought there's no way you
can have like antigen tests at hundreds
of millions
like order hundreds of millions of them
and make them cheap but actually
i realized recently that they've been
available since about like
may yeah you were able to in korea in
finland
all over the place you could have done
mass manufacture so there
there's a little bit of a failure of uh
of capitalism to step up yeah and i
don't know if you agree with this but
it seems that the blame is to be placed
at the regulators
and the the the various institutions
crony capitalism and all likelihood
is what stopped it here in america i
mean
i had friends who had imported them from
other countries
the testing kits and you've probably
been to parties where people had these
kind of testing kits from other
countries
and we're sitting here and they're just
approving them now really in february
month 11 of the pandemic in america
we're going to have testing online
really i mean even if these tests were
80
you know effective and they're 95
effective
mass producing them we should have sent
them you know in
every postal anybody with a post office
box should have
you know with the mailing address should
have had 10 of them put in their mailing
address just for free from the
government
and then everybody would be testing and
we would have contained it we don't have
test and trace here in the united states
all the countries that
are on the other side of kovid did it by
having testing
tracing and closing their borders and
masks
that's the combination that works the
the problem with
the coronavirus is uh while there's a
lot of institutions did not behave their
best
it's also the case that there's a lot of
uncertainty so i tend to give a little
bit of a pass
to everybody involved for the
uncertainty
we were all i give them that until june
i wonder how history will remember this
whole period
you